let's bring in Seth Davis CBS sports
college basketball analyst and has a new
book getting to us how great coaches
make great teams comes out later on
today
Seth thanks for joining us good morning
I'm just trying to make sense of all of
this with one in Duns if we raise the
age to now 18 and a half or you know
where are we headed with college
basketball when it comes to this one and
done well let's keep in mind that this
is not first of all there's not a
college basketball you know like this is
between the NBA owners and the Players
Association and that's first of all I
kind of laugh when people say what when
I'm done as bad for college basketball
let's remember before those one-and-done
there was none and done so it's college
basketball better off with DeAndre Aten
and Marvin Bagley playing in college or
playing in the NBA right now so from a
marketing and business standpoint it's
been a huge boon for college basketball
I personally man feel like if the Boston
Celtics on a draft a 13 year old kid in
paying five million dollars I'm totally
fine with it
like I got no problems raising my own
kids I think there's the you know an
open market and there should be no age
minimum whatsoever but however that
plays out I encourage people to separate
that from what's going on with the FBI
because it has absolutely nothing to do
with one and done one another plies to
maybe three or four kids every year you
telling me if there's if kids can go to
the league the ones who go to college
they're going to turn down money from
agents and boosters so there's a lot
going on there but I think the would've
done you know to me I just get rid of it
and let them let them leave when they
want to leave it doesn't bother me in
the slightest we thought college
basketball was going to come down
crashing here a week ago with what's
happened with Arizona and Sean Miller
and the wiretap and payments and you
know Rick Pitino paid the price but
where do we stand with this
investigation
Pitino paid the price probably because
of what's already going on so I think
you know in this isolated case worth in
the would have not been fired I guess
we'll never know but listen Dan this
case is going to take one to two years
to play itself out and so we're getting
certain leaks and pieces of information
through the media we don't know how
nearly enough information to
no I mean it's obviously not correct and
I think the important thing is you know
it's disappointing to me that it takes a
crisis to create some change that should
have been created a long time ago but if
there does seem to be some momentum
through this collision that Mark Emmert
has put together that we can open up the
agent area maybe open up the marketing
area and a lot of other things but as
far as the apocalypse coming I mean
let's let the facts dictate that as
opposed to the speculation but you know
a couple of bits and pieces of
information when there's a lot more
information coming out I'm gonna play
this Tubby Smith rant and I want to get
your thoughts on this so Seaton if
you'll play that with the new NC
double-a regulations and guys can
transfer when they want I've been in
this business long time never seen like
we're 800 division 1 players transfer
last year over 800 teach them how to
quit as we're doing things are going
well that's quick I remember calling my
dad when I was a freshman
dad I'm people that read on this and I'm
kind of happy here one more to blacks in
the whole school
hey sir son somebody do something to you
know they still you're still getting
your scholarship ah gee they still feed
you mr. Halden you're still getting
education yes sir so you can't come home
your bears been taken but you can join
the army best thing you ever said to me
something I need to tell them that hey
you made a commitment stick to it
doesn't happen that way they got a lot
of people near life is my tubby smith
who's the Memphis head coach what do you
make of these comments the problem is
especially you know and the basketball
culture and the grassroots culture is
this type of attitude is in place long
before they get there I mean the kids
are changing high schools it's very
unusual man it took like the 250
recruits that any of them would only be
in one high school they're all the
action is every other week oh my kids
obviously there have my genetics they're
not going to be Division one athletes
but they all play club soccer and
there's all kinds of switching around
routines the parents aren't happy so
I will say this so you know I think that
you know it's similar what I said about
one-and-done but do you think there is a
positive in kids having opportunities if
a kid is in a situation where he's not
getting playing time or he's in a
situation where he's unhappy with the
coach for very valid reasons for them to
have those opportunities for change
I like opportunity but I completely
agree with the sentiment that you know
kids aren't sticking out difficult
situations and by the way that's not
limited just to college basketball
that's very pervasive in society but it
took me resonated with me as as a fan
someone who covers the sport and
definitely as a parent yeah you know
what bothered me about that his tubby
smith didn't make any mention of
coaching situations he's had six
different jobs has he taken a job as he
bolted to a new job why didn't he stick
it out did he honor his contract every
single time you know these coaches do
this as well why is it that it's always
the kids who make the mistakes and it's
never the grown-ups here yeah it's I
completely agree with that and that's
you know the whole the moaning of the
transferor thing you know comes across
as very old school and then what I
really don't like is when they are you
may disagree with a young man's decision
to transfer or you may not like it but
the fact that schools have the ability
to not release kids to certain schools
whether it's inside their own
conferences or they'll say if somebody's
on our schedule you can't play there you
see coaches abusing that all the time so
no that is I think you make a great
point with that I'm personally not in
favor of open season transfer and
whether they don't have to sit out I
think you could transfer you got to sit
out of here but if you want to transfer
some learners should be able to go
wherever you want
you got a new book how great coaches
make great teams it's called getting to
us what was the reasoning behind doing
this book you know I coaches over the
years as a long form writer coaches made
for great characters because they're
brilliant they're intelligent they're
driven and are absolutely tortured so I
was able to find mine coaches six in
basketball and three input balls so my
six basketball coaches are my Chesky Jim
Boeheim Geno Auriemma
Doc Rivers and Brad Stevens been in
football Jim Harbaugh Urban Meyer and
Davo Sweeney I wrote nine long chapters
about them got great access to then
their wives their families their players
and colleagues and really tried to break
down how they develop their personal
qualities that make them great leaders
how they totes their teams why their
teams win you know the common threads
and then the uncommon threads obviously
nine very different personalities in
that book and they're a lot of different
ways to lead so it really becomes you
know a character psychological study as
much as it is a prank down on leadership
so it was a lot of fun out today and I
can't imagine a better way to promote
this book than being on with Dan Patrick
before I let you go I wanted to ask you
about and not that we get caught up in
this but you work for CBS there's no
that that it guy that you want to see in
this tournament I mean if Trey young
maybe but that's kind of cooled off
there's no that it team that you want to
see that's great how much of a concern
do you think that is for the network
says as we go into this tournament and
we get caught up in the madness here but
you don't have that player and you don't
have that team very true on both counts
but I think if you look at the history
of the tournament it's probably more
common than you might realize certainly
from the perspective of the team like I
I know that every year well there's no
dominant scene this year well it's
actually the exception when there is a
dominant team and I think the great
thing about the tournament and I'm
ceiling obviously but I'm not just
showing because I'm a fan first is is
you know I remember I remember Bob Ryan
saying there's one time to really hit on
the head the NCAA tournament tournament
doesn't need stars because the NCA
tournament creates stars because those
moments that you don't expect to happen
listen a lot of these games are snoozers
right I watch them all they're not all
scintillating games but in the course of
the 67 games being played there's going
to be five or six of them but are the
kind of epic games that you're going to
be talking about for decades really so
that's why we watch the tournament
nothing is perfect but I think the
tournament is about as bulletproof as it
gets in terms of an entertainment
sporting event he Seth Davis the book is
getting to us how great coaches make
great teams comes out today chef thanks
for joining us we'll talk to you during
the tournament
love you Dan Thank You bud that's Seth
Davis mercedes-amg driver's seat brings
Youssef Davis 2018 mercedes-amg eClass
with a suite of innovative technologies
it's one of the most intelligent cars on
the road go to MBUSA dot-com or visit
your local dealership to schedule your
test drive today for more Dan Patrick
show to the audience channel 239 on
DirecTV or download the Dan Patrick show
app
[Music]